Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnesigespräch durchführen. Damit sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ich einverstanden.
Okay, also bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie nicht etwas verstehen.
Ich werde Ihnen gerne ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen, bevor Sie über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen. Ist das in Ordnung?
Ja, okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich bin Irane Langer.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam kusschebbieren?
Ja, Ida, Richard, Emil, Nordpol, Emil, Ludwig, Anton, Nordpol, Gustav, Emil. Irane Langer.
Frau Langer, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 76 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
20. Juni 1948.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 71 Kilogramm.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 76.
Okay, danke für die Formation. Frau Langer, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zurzeit?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe starke Bauchschmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ich habe seit drei Tagen diese Beschwerden, Doktor.
Wo genau sind diese Schmerzen, Frau Langer?
Meine Schmerzen sind mein Unterbau.
Welche Seite meinen Sie?
Linker Unterbau.
Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Sind sie eher drückend oder brennend?
Ja, ich verstehe. Die Schmerzen sind steckender, drückender und dunfer.
Strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo aus?
Nein, sie strahlen sie nicht aus.
Sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Die Schmerzen treten plötzlich aus.
Frau Langer, haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden früher gehabt?
Ja, Doktor. Vor einem halben Jahr hatte ich ähnliche Beschwerden.
Und waren Sie damals bei einem Arzt gewesen? Ich meine wegen dieser Schmerzen, Beschwerden?
Nein. Ich habe eine Schmerzmittel gegeben.
Das war mir geholfen. Ich habe nicht bei einem anderen Arzt gegangen.
Welches Medikament haben Sie genommen?
Ibuprofen. 500 mg. Aber früher habe ich es genommen.
Und haben Sie heutzutage wegen dieser Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ich habe kein Medikament eingenommen. Nein.
Wie stark sind Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10? Wobei 1 sehr leichte und 10 sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht?
Ich würde sie mit 8 bis 10 Punkten beschreiben.
Frau Langer, das ist eine starke Schmerzen.
Soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel geben oder können Sie noch ein bisschen diese Schmerzen bis Ende des Sprechs aushalten?
Ich kann warten, Doktor.
Okay. Bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid, wenn Sie ein Medikament benötigen.
Okay. Danke schön.
Alles klar. Sehr gerne. Frau Langer, haben Sie einen bestimmten Auslöser für diese Schmerzen bemerkt?
Ich meine nach dem Essen oder Stress?
Ich habe keinen Auslöser bemerkt. Aber wenn ich mich nach vorne beuge, werden die Schmerzen etwas besser. Verstehen Sie?
Ja, ich verstehe sehr gut. Frau Langer. Alles klar. Frau Langer, leiden Sie unter Luftnot oder Husten?
Ich habe keine Luft- und Husten-Doktor. Nein.
Okay.
Aber ich habe auch Fieber, Doktor.
Nächstes Mal werde ich diese Frage stellen. Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Fieber haben. Ja?
Haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Ich habe 38,9 Fieber gemessen.
Okay. Und haben Sie Stress oder Nachtschmerzen?
Ich habe ein bisschen Stress, aber keine Nachtschmerzen oder Kaltschmerzen.
Okay. Alles klar. Frau Langer, darf ich fragen, ob Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang haben?
Ich habe seit drei Tagen Verstopfung.
Seit drei Tagen? Ja.
Seit drei Tagen Verstopfung. Ja.
Verstopfung. Also, wann war Ihr letzter Stuhlgang? Darf ich fragen?
Zwei Tage. Gestern habe ich die Toilette für Verstopfung, für Stuhlgang entschuldigt.
Gestern, ja? Okay. Ja, gestern, ja.
Haben Sie im Stuhl eine Farbeveränderung bemerkt oder Blut zum Beispiel?
Nein, ich habe keine Farbeveränderungen oder Blut bemerkt.
Okay. Alles klar. Und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe seit heute Morgen Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen.
Okay. Verstehe. Und wie oft müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Ich denke, es ist normal. Aber wenn ich Wasser lasse, habe ich Schmerzen.
Schmerzen. Aber nicht häufig. Richtig?
Nicht häufig, ja.
Okay. Und haben Sie Blut im Urin bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Alles klar. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Appetit? Ich habe keinen Appetit.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen oder?
Ich schlafe wegen dieser Schmerzen. Ich denke.
Ja, okay. Und Sie haben auch Schlafstörungen, richtig?
Ja, ja. Wegen der Schmerzen. Okay.
Für drei Tage habe ich Schlafstörungen.
Also diese Probleme sind einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Ich habe das einschlafen, ja. Oder weiter.
Weiter, okay.
Ich bin nicht sicher jetzt.
Okay, alles klar. Alles klar.
Frau Lange, sind Sie schon vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft und gegen Corona dreimal.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit, ich meine besonders in den letzten sechs Monaten, eine Reise ins Ausland gemacht?
Ja, vor drei Jahren fahre ich mit meiner Familie nach Frankreich.
Vor drei Jahren, richtig?
Drei Monate, Entschuldigung.
Okay. Frankreich, ja.
Okay. Frau Lange, leiten Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, ja. Ich habe Bluthochdruck seit zehn Jahren.
Und was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ja, und wir nehmen dagegen einen April 10 mg Tablet täglich morgens.
Ein Tablet morgens, ja.
Ja, sonst noch?
Und 10 mg Tablet täglich, einmal.
Auch morgens?
Ja, auch morgens, ja.
Okay.
Außerdem habe ich seit zwei Jahren Zuckerkrankheit.
Und nehme mit Formin 850 mg täglich morgens.
Okay. Ja, noch irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Ja, wegen einer Arthrose im rechten Knie nehme ich bei Bedarf ibuprofen.
500 mg. Aber bei Bedarf nicht regelmäßig.
Okay, alles klar.
Ja. Das war es, oder?
Ja, das war es, ja.
Okay. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, Doktor. Als ich 20 Jahre alt war, hatte ich einen Skiunfall.
Und mein Bein ist gebrochen. Deswegen wurde bei mir eine Operation mit einer Platte durchgeführt.
Also Unterbein oder Oberbein?
Unterbein.
Oberbein und Sie haben rechte Seite, richtig?
Ja, rechte Seite.
Okay. Ja. Irgendwelche andere Operationen hatten Sie?
Ja, ich habe keine andere Operation.
Okay.
Waren Sie Unterschenkel?
Entschuldigung?
Unterschenkel, ja.
Frau Lange, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf andere Medikamente außer genannten Medikamenten?
Nein, ich habe keine anderen Medikamente eingenommen, nein.
Alles klar.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen irgendwelche Medikamente oder Pflanzen?
Ja, ich habe eine Aspirinunverträglichkeit.
Wie ersetzt sich diese Allergie?
Es äußert mit Atemnoten.
Und sonst?
Eine andere Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit.
Frau Lange, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich habe jetzt nicht rauchen. Rauchen seit 26 Jahren nicht mehr.
Aber davor habe ich etwa 30 Jahre lang 15 Zigaretten pro Tag geraucht.
Okay. Frau Lange, Sie haben eine sehr gute Entscheidung getroffen für Ihre Gesundheit.
Ich gratuliere Ihnen, ja.
Es war schwer, aber ich habe es verstanden.
Gratuliere Ihnen. Super.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Am Wochenende trinke ich manchmal ein Glas Rotwein.
Okay. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich habe keine Drogen genommen, Doktor.
Okay, das freut mich.
Frau Lange, Sie sind jetzt 76 Jahre alt. Darf ich fragen, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Leider, Doktor. Meine Mutter hat mit 65 Jahren an Herzrhythmstörungen und Darmkrebs gestorben.
Mein Vater ist mit 70 Jahren an Schlaganfall gestorben.
Okay. Mein Beileid, Frau Lange.
Ja.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe vier Kinder. Drei davon leben, eine ist gestorben.
Sie haben drei Kinder?
Jetzt drei Kinder. Aber früher hatte ich vier Kinder. Ein Kind ist gestorben.
Okay. Mein Beileid. Also woran?
Er hatte einen Schlechtumfall.
Verkehrsunfall, meinen Sie?
Ja, Verkehrsunfall.
Okay. Frau Lange, haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin ein Einzelkind.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verwittert.
Okay. Frau Lange, Sie sind jetzt Rentnerin. Aber was haben Sie früher als Beruflich gemacht?
Ich habe früher als Schülerin gearbeitet.
Schülerin, meinen Sie? Ja, okay. Also Entzündung haben, ich meine.
Also das ist eine Entzündung des Darms als Ausstürmung.
Deswegen werde ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen und dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Okay. Und sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen die weitere Information mitteilen.
Okay, Doktor. Können Sie mir sagen, ob ich in Krankenhaus bleiben muss oder gehe ich mein Haus?
Frau Lange, also ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben, damit wir die Diagnose bestätigen können und eine Therapie einstellen können.
Aber es kann auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen.
Okay, okay Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie. Danke.
Okay, bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Wartezimmer. Ich bin gleich wieder da. Danke schön Doktor.